Yes,
I think there are elements of the game
that you should teach in terms of like
teaching because what poker really does
is teach you how to deal with
probabilities and uncertainties.
And that's so integral to life,
you know,
with everything,
everything we tried to do,
you know,
should we take this route or that route?
Should I go here on vacation?
Or they're,
it's all about dealing with w with
uncertainties and probabilities of
things happening and,
and poker is a very fun and easy way to
teach someone how to do that.
Um,
it's a shame.
People often put poker in the same
ballpark as,
as just general gambling.
Um,
just because some people choose to play
it for money,
but you don't have to play it for money.
It's just about about winning.
You can win anything.
He can win prizes,
you can win match six or money.
Um,
and that there are so many like core
fundamentals of the game that I wish I
have no age,
age 10.
The these idea that these sort of ways
of thinking about expectation,
expected value and um,
what probabilistic thinking in general,
that would have sped up a lot of things
in my life had I been more aware of it.
And also learning how to evaluate
evidence.
Um,
that's something that is not taught in
school.
Very rarely taught in school.
Learning how to change our minds,
update our beliefs,
uh,
look at,
you know,
when we get new information,
being able to wait is that inflammation
or reliable or not?
And playing poker has taught me how to
do those much more accurately.
Um,
so if,
if,
if there's a way to teach children's for
a game and children love to learn
through games,
poker could be that one of those
methods.
I think something like being
mathematically minded is,
I mean,
yeah,
there's probably some aptitude involved
in it.
Um,
but I still think it's,
the vast majority of it is down to
determination and practice.
Uh,
you can take someone,
I mean,
if you can just understand the concept
of numbers in the first place,
which I think the vast majority of
humans can,
then you can train someone to be more
mathematically capable.
It's like learning a language.
You know,
you start off,
as long as you have that initial passion
and desire to get better,
then there's those little incremental
jumps.
And it makes me so sad when I meet
people who are like,
oh,
I'm no good at math and I'm good at
math.
And if you actually keep asking them why
and go back in their history,
it almost always comes down to some bad
experience they had when they were
probably seven years old.
And the teacher asked them,
you know,
what's five times five?
And they screwed up and their friends
laughed at them and then they just,
you know,
these barriers get built and they're
like,
oh,
that's not my thing.
Um,
and I think that's just a huge tragedy
because most humans can learn,
be at least competent at,
at basic mathematics,
especially the mathematics in involved
in poker.
It's really not that complicated.
Um,
there's a lot of approximations you can
do.
And I,
I found that I used to actually not be
very good at mental arithmetic.
Um,
I'm fine if I had a pen and paper and
Algebra that was,
I liked that,
but in the moments,
men's,
mental arithmetic,
I could never do.
But I started playing poker inside of
just practicing these things.
And now I,
it's a skill I'm proud of.
So it's,
it's,
it's just a willingness to,
to keep plugging away at it.